hey you guys it's flickers of fear time
once again and i'm doing a movie this i
actually didn't really mean for this to
happen but it just kind of happened
accidentally uh this is the one that's
going up the day before halloween
unless you're a patron it'll go up the
day before two days before halloween uh
and i had actually forgotten even though
i've seen this movie a couple of times
that this movie is set on halloween uh
it's not a huge plot point it only kind
of comes into play at the end so it's
not like overtly halloween but
so you know so that's kind of a nice
little uh little extra there that i
didn't actually intend to happen
now this movie
is one of my favorite movies from the
2000s and i feel like it's one that is
really very sadly
underrated uh this is the 2002 film may
directed by lucky mckee this was
actually his first film and also his
first collaboration with the actress
angela bettis and uh he would do some
other stuff with her later on i think he
did a masters of horror episode back in
whenever that was that they made those i
kept i don't even remember what year
that was 2005. i don't even remember but
uh yeah he did one and she played kind
of a similar character in that one she
was like an entomologist or you know the
the one that studies bugs is that
etymologist or entomologist i think
that's entomologist yeah but she played
uh the similar type of character
and honestly
this movie is kind of like just uh a
tour de force for her she is just so
great in this
so this movie
it's kind of like a i guess i would call
it like more like a psychological horror
and it also has some elements of like
black comedy in it
and it doesn't actually get into i mean
there's some gore in it and some
uncomfortable [ __ ] but most of the
killings and stuff like that doesn't
happen until the third act so a lot of
the first two parts of the movie are
kind of like build up but i think that's
what makes this
such a great film because you really get
emotionally invested in the main
character
and you're essentially like watching
a woman who you actually develop a lot
of sympathy for
um slowly kind of like losing her mind
and i think that makes for like a really
effective film and like i said it also
has like some dark comedy elements in it
as well and i just think it's just a
really really well done
film and you know i've seen some other
horror channels covering it and stuff
but i kind of do feel like it's not
all that widely known i mean even when
they first released it back in 2002 i
think what i want to say was maybe
lionsgate or something like that but i
think they only released it in like nine
theaters it was almost kind of like they
didn't even bother with the [ __ ] and
it's like i think it only costs like a
million or a million and a half to make
and it didn't even make that back but it
does seem like it's kind of gotten the
cult following in the years since so
that's nice to see uh but yeah i'm just
gonna join the chorus of voices saying
that this movie's really super
underrated and uh if you're into
kind of quirky weird
horror that also has like an emotional
element to it and has some good gore in
it as well then i think you should
definitely check this out as of this
recording a couple days of before
halloween 2021 this is actually on 2b
for free so you can watch it on there
and it won't cost you anything and i
definitely would recommend that you
watch it uh but obviously i'm probably
gonna spoil a lot of the [ __ ] that
happens in the movie and i think it's
better to go into it not really knowing
what's gonna happen so if you wanna
watch it and you haven't seen it then go
to 2b and watch it right now and then
come back and watch my little breakdown
of it so as i said this came out in
2002. angela bettis plays a young woman
named may canady
and they kind of do a little bit of her
childhood
where you can see that you where you can
see like that a lot of her psychological
damage and trauma and stuff like that
came from
so when she was a little girl she had a
really bad lazy eye
and she also had
a mom who seemed like one of those
really perfect
women who like everything has to be just
so so you could tell that she was kind
of like
trying to fix may's eye you know so
she'd put like an eye patch on her it's
like you know we you won't make friends
if you you know have a messed up eye and
just [ __ ] like that so you can see that
she's
never really had anybody that accepted
her the way she was and you know was
always kind of like her mom was always
kind of like she there was something
about her that needed to be fixed
so
in turn she kind of becomes
obsessed with perfection also
and you know getting to a point where
she can't really attain it because
obviously if you're a little girl and
you're wearing an eye patch at school
everyone's gonna like think you're a
freak and a weirdo and that isolates her
and you know so it goes about as well as
you would expect so because she doesn't
really have a lot of friends her mom
gives her this doll that she made named
suzy and the doll's like pretty creepy
um and she gives it to her and the mom
says something which will be significant
later on she says you know i always said
if you can't you know make friends then
you should kind of like create your own
so she had made this doll and she's like
i made this doll when i was a kid and
now i'm giving it to you
but the thing about it is that this doll
is in like this elaborate glass case
and the mom won't let little mae like
take it out so she basically is just
kind of like you have to keep her
perfect she can't come out of the box
so then we jump ahead to you know
several years later
and may is now a grown woman
and she works at a veterinary clinic i
guess she's like a vet's assistant so
she like helps out with the surgeries uh
you know on the dogs and cats and
everything and she is clearly
very very lonely and very very awkward
and i think the best thing about this
movie is that
angela bettis gives like such a great
performance because i kind of feel like
it would be really easy
for a character like this to either fall
too far into
maybe parody or
or just being like really off-putting or
annoying or something like that but it
doesn't come off that way at all even
though she is obviously very very
awkward and very like some of this
some of this stuff that she does and
says and like the way she walks and
stuff like that it's just very
you just feel so bad for her because
even though she's tremendously awkward
and seems to like push people away you
still sympathize with her because she
still seems like a really sweet good
person and you just feel bad for her
because she's having such a hard time
connecting with the world around her so
even though she's very mentally ill and
i mean clearly you still kind of like
sympathize with her and you want her to
get out there and get better and you
want things to get better for her so
like i said she really threaded that
needle really well
i'm just making this obviously a very
very damaged awkward character but still
making you pretty much immediately feel
for her and get emotionally invested in
her welfare
so she's uh become obsessed like i said
she's very very lonely she still has the
doll suzy in her apartment and it's in
the glass box she's never taken it out
and she basically talks to the doll as
though it's real because it's the only
friend that she's ever had now she has a
thing again where and she probably got
this from her you know [ __ ] up
childhood with her mom
saying stuff like you know her mom being
kind of obsessed with perfection and may
seems like she's also kind of obsessed
with perfection she's gotten to the
point now where
she wears glasses for the lazy eye and
it kind of like pulls it back in place
and that at the very beginning she's
very excited because she gets contact
lenses and the contact lenses that she
gets um you know help the lazy eye so
she looks you know quote unquote normal
like her face looks normal again like
for the first time so she's very very
excited that you know now this is it i'm
gonna be i'm gonna be able to make
friends now because i don't have that
one thing that's that imperfection
but she's kind of obsessed with
perfection in other people and she sort
of says she she tends to fixate on
parts of people's bodies that she
particularly likes so she finds
aesthetically pleasing so like i said
you kind of tell where this is going
like pretty much from the very beginning
but that does not diminish uh the impact
of the film at all even though like i
said you pretty much know where it's
going you know from the outset from some
of the stuff that she says
so she has become
enamored
of this dude played by jeremy sisto
named adam and he is a mechanic who you
know works in the same area you know
that she works in and she's seen him and
she's kind of like watching him from
afar
now
she likes him a lot but she mostly likes
his hands she's always kind of like
obsessing about how beautiful his hands
are and
her kind of like hoping that
that it won't just be his hands that are
beautiful that he'll be beautiful like
he'll be perfect uh as a whole person
instead of just apart
so she kind of sets about once she gets
her contact lenses and you know her lazy
eyes fixed and everything she kind of
sets about trying to
get his attention but like in in like
the saddest kind of way possible because
like i said she's grown up not having
any friends she doesn't really know how
to interact with human beings in a
normal sort of way and she's like you
know she's a little weird she's like
into like i said she works at a vet
clinic and she's not grossed out by
amputation or blood or
anything like that so she likes really
gross [ __ ] and she's just very
comfortable with that and like i said
she just comes across as
someone who doesn't know how people
interact with one another so she tries
to kind of like put herself in the path
of this guy that she's noticing but he
doesn't really notice her at first um
she goes she like dresses up really nice
and like goes to this coffee shop where
he is and he's there like studying or
something like that and um she just
keeps
kind of trying to put herself in
his line of vision and he's just like
not paying any attention and then
finally he falls asleep
and because she's so weird and awkward
she basically goes over there and puts
her face like in his hand like while
he's sleeping which you know like i said
pro tip don't do that because it's a
little weird
so uh she does that and like obviously
he wakes up and then she kind of like
falls down and she's like oh [ __ ] like i
[ __ ] that all up but the thing about
it though is that the more she kind of
tries to put herself in the way of him
he does actually sort of
try to you know he starts to kind of
notice her because like i said even
though she's very weird and awkward and
stuff like that she is like a very
pretty girl and uh so he does kind of
see and she's like he's like yeah she's
kind of weird but
one of his things too is like oh i
really like weird which little does he
know but yeah we'll get into that in a
minute but so they actually kind of end
up
you know having a little bit of a of a
thing like they go and sit on the bench
and eat lunch together and he's like oh
i really like gross [ __ ] he's really
into horror movies and so she tells him
like all this disgusting stuff about
like the vet clinic like the grossest
[ __ ] ever and uh all this other stuff so
it kind of progresses to a point where
uh she is invited over to his house and
he is apparently like really into super
into dario argento i spotted an opera
poster back there but yeah he's got like
a bunch of dario argento stuff and he's
also kind of like an amateur horror
filmmaker so at one point he shows her
this student film that he made
i think it's called jack and jill and
it's basically about these two people
and it's black and white and they go on
this picnic and then as it goes on they
actually start cannibalizing one another
now so he shows this to mae and she's
really into it i mean she's kind of like
as she would be
and uh so
she she basically says something like um
you know she's like yeah i really liked
it i thought it was really sweet
and then she said but one thing that was
far-fetched was i don't think that the
girl would be able to get his whole
entire finger in her mouth like him take
it off in one bite or whatever so she's
giving like criticism like that so i
thought it was really funny so you know
obviously he's into horror movies she's
into that kind of stuff so they kind of
like connect on that level but then
um something kind of awkward happens
where as soon as they start to make out
because she's never done this before she
gets like really overzealous and starts
like acting really weird and it sort of
like puts him off
and then after that she seems to kind of
like not was kind of like low-key stalk
him because she doesn't really
understand that you know he kind of he's
kind of like weirded out by her
and uh you know she doesn't really know
how to take rejection or anything so she
still kind of keeps hanging around
and to his credit he does actually seem
to like her uh even though she's a
little strange
so and also i think he kind of feels bad
because she just keeps like hanging
around and she seems to like him a lot
you know and they seem to have a few
things in common so he actually does
kind of give her another chance so they
end up they kind of like start to have
sex or whatever but then she ends up
like biting him in the lip and then she
gets all into it like starts rubbing his
blood all over her face and everything
and he's just like wait a minute you
know what i mean he's like this is going
a little too far and she's like yeah but
i thought you said you liked weird and
he's like yeah not that weird
so that's basically the end of that but
what ends up happening again is she
still kind of like hangs around
and she goes and waits outside of his
apartment or something like that one
night and she overhears him like talking
to his roommate and also there's another
girl there that he's like started dating
and he's talking about how weird she is
and like how he's glad he got rid of her
and all this other kind of stuff so
obviously like that hurts her feelings a
lot now while all that's going on um you
know her getting her heart broken by
adam
there's also um a young woman who works
at the same she's like the receptionist
at the vet uh clinic and she's played by
anna faris her character's name is polly
and polly is actually um very attracted
to mae
and she's always kind of like flirting
with her and stuff so after
adam uh finally like rejects her and she
overhears adam talking about what a
weirdo she is um polly who's been kind
of be like why don't you come over and
we'll do this and she's very very
flirtatious very thirsty one could say
uh so may finally uh breaks down it's
like okay fine she's so so lonely that
she's really willing to
you know take anything polly is actually
like a really beautiful girl and does
actually seem uh very attracted to me so
you know she's she's like that's that's
fine so they kind of start making out
too and polly says a similar thing too
that she thinks may is weird but she's
like i love weird but like i said that's
one of the kind of themes of this and
this is something that kind of resonated
with me a lot i think the first time
that i saw this movie back in the early
2000s
was that
may is such a tragic character because
you know she's obviously very awkward
she's obviously very isolated she's very
lonely she doesn't know how to connect
with people how to interact with people
at all
and even when she does have some glimmer
of hope that like somebody seems to like
her and she's always like you know don't
you mind that i'm weird and they're
always like i like weird but then when
she actually
acts the way she acts they're like yeah
that's not the kind of weird that i'm
talking about so she is like weird but
not the same kind of weird that these
people apparently think she is she's
like way weirder than uh than they are
willing to handle so there's kind of so
that's what's kind of sad about it too
is that she gets her hopes up because
they're like oh they said they liked a
weird person but they're like yeah not
that kind of weird and that's what makes
it doubly sad so she's kind of like
making out with polly and everything and
that seems to be going okay too but then
it turns out that polly is just very
kind of she's just like promiscuous
she's not really into like having a
serious relationship or anything because
mae goes over to her house like a day or
two later and you know there's another
girl there named ambrosia
of all things like this kind of like
really tall thin beautiful model type
like with blonde hair and everything and
basically polly's like oh you know it's
it's nothing serious it's just sex it's
you know don't worry about it and uh she
kind of teases me a little bit for
getting jealous and everything so may is
starting to
get to the point where she's like you
know all these people that supposedly
liked me and stuff like that just kind
of like [ __ ] me over because she
doesn't really understand like how human
relationships work so she's getting more
and more disillusioned with all of these
relationships
and so she kind of starts to she wants
to do something else
so she um i guess she starts to go she
goes and volunteers at this school for
the blind or whatever um because she has
kind of she's seen this little girl who
reminds her of her like when she was
younger and the little girl's very
isolated she's always kind of like apart
from the other kids and she's kind of
she sort of has like an attitude like
with the other teachers and things like
that so uh so may thinks that she can
maybe get through to this girl
so she does kind of connect with her a
little bit but then she makes the
mistake of bringing her precious doll
susie who was her you know her best
friend since she was a kid
she brings it to the school like for a
show-and-tell type situation
and the blind kids you know they're just
feeling the outside of the box and she's
like oh my best friend is in here and
they're like we'll take her out we can't
you know we can't
obviously feel her from like it just
feels like a glass box she's like no she
never comes out it's like i can't but
then it ends up that like the the box
ends up getting broken and uh you know
the kids are kind of like milling around
and the doll ends up getting broken so
of course she's just completely crushed
now she gets to a point too i mean
there's a there's kind of an upsetting
scene too where she had had a cat that
she adopted from the vet
and i guess even the cat was just kind
of like no i don't really want to hang
out with you right now and maybe like
throws
an ashtray that the little blind girl
had given her and uh ends up killing the
cat which makes her feel really bad and
she basically wraps up the cat and puts
it in the freezer so at this point she's
pretty much gone off the deep end you
know understandably so i guess uh from
you know from everything that's happened
to her in the movie and knowing what her
mental state was like
so she decides that uh much like her
mother used to tell her i was like look
if you are having problems making
friends you need to create one so as i
said it's not uh a stretch of the
imagination as you will see
coming that what she decides to do
is take only the good parts of the
people uh that she knows and make it and
take them and make it into one like
perfect friend so basically she'll go to
adam and she'll get his hands um she
told polly earlier that she thought she
had a beautiful neck um you know things
like that so
she basically it's halloween night she
makes a costume where she kind of
dresses up like susie the doll that was
her best friend that's all busted up now
she also kind of like seems to
oh she gets like really confident at
that point like she starts talking
normal instead of her little weird
awkward voice she you know is walking
much more upright because she's kind of
decided what she's going to do she's
like i'm just going to take the parts of
these people that i like
um and discard the parts that i don't
like and i'm going to take all the parts
together and i will make like the
perfect friend so that's essentially
what she tries to do so it's halloween
night and she essentially goes around
she starts out with this like punk rock
kid who sort of uh befriends her on on a
bench
and uh she that was kind of like her
last ditch effort i guess like to make a
friend and he comes back to her
apartment and sees the dead cat in the
freezer and obviously starts calling her
freaking stuff so she kills him and
takes his arms because she liked his uh
he had a frankenstein tattoo uh you know
a little on the nose but you know what i
mean so she liked the arms so she took
those and got rid of the rest of him and
then she basically goes around to
everybody that she knows and takes
the parts of the body the parts of their
bodies that she likes the best and
discards the rest of them so uh so she
gets home and she uh stitches them all
back together she makes a little outfit
and she takes the um the ashtray that
the little blind girl made for her the
little blind girl's name was petey by
the way
that had her name on it and it broke
when she threw it at the cat so she
rearranges the uh the letters into amy
so that's gonna be amy her perfect
friend
and uh so she has it all put together
it's laying on the bed and she starts
getting upset because can you see me not
not literally but you know can you see
me like as something other than a weirdo
or a freak because that's the only way
that anyone has ever seen her they never
saw her as a person really they always
just saw her as like this weird awkward
girl that they didn't really want
anything to do with because she was kind
of off-putting so she decides that the
only thing to do is to is to give amy
her own eye so she basically there's a
pretty like yucky scene toward the end
where she basically cuts out her lazy
eye
and gives it to amy like just kind of
lays it on top of the of the swaddling
or whatever and uh then she kind of like
cuddles up next to it and in the very
last scene of the movie which actually i
love this i love this
in the very last scene of the movie um
she's sitting there going do you see me
do you see me and the eye kind of rolls
off the face but then amy the you know
the the frankenstein monster type
creature like comes to life and the arm
comes up and it's you know the punk rock
kid's arm and adam's hand and it just
like starts stroking her face like while
she's laying next to it so she has
indeed obviously that's probably like
all in her head or whatever but you know
she has created the perfect friend and
the friend is always going to be there
for her you know obviously even though
she's
tremendously mentally ill has murdered
many many people
but the interesting thing about this
movie is that
you really i mean yes it has a tone of
like dark comedy to it so
you know and because her character is so
sympathetic
you almost don't feel bad like when she
kills the people even though some of the
people like paulie in particular uh is a
very likable character um some of the
other ones not so much adam's kind of a
jerk you know the the other woman
ambrosia who uh polly's new girlfriend
or whatever she's like an [ __ ] so you
don't really feel all that bad when mei
kind of goes on a killing spree because
they're all kind of like jerks like i
said the only one i felt bad about was
polly and the cat obviously
you know because you know you know how
cats are they don't mean anything by it
by like not paying attention to you or
whatever but
so you can almost i'm not saying that
people deserve to die or anything but
you can tell that may has just been put
through so much like through her whole
entire life and she's just so lonely and
she's never had a friend and every
single person that she you know gets
hopeful about like this person will
accept me the way that i am they always
like reject her in the end so it just
gets to a point where it builds up and
builds up and she just loses her marbles
and you know decides to go on a killing
spree and just sew everybody together so
she can have a friend that she likes
that understands her ultimately so as i
said if you have not seen
this movie i feel like it's just really
really underrated it's just so
it's so like heartbreaking it's a really
really sad and i think i said this too
when i was talking about the devil's
backbone it's one of those horror movies
that's just it's obviously a horror
movie but it's all it's like so sad and
like so tragic because you feel so bad
like for for the central character you
feel so bad for mae and just how every
like hope that she has is dashed and
it's just every time she tries to do
something it comes out wrong or people
reject her they pick on her and it's
just kind of like and you know and and
her getting like anger the rage and
anger and stuff like that it's just like
so sad to see that you're almost kind of
like reading mortal that killed people i
know it's kind of [ __ ] up to say but i
think the tone of it works just because
it like i said it does have those dark
humor elements to it
i will say too that it's interesting i
guess this is very early 2000s in the
sense of like the fashions you know is
like the kind of indie fashions uh also
the the soundtrack has a lot of stuff
like the breeders and stuff like that on
it like kelly deal and uh so it is very
much
of its time in the sense that you know
you it's very clear that it's set in the
early 2000s but that said i kind of feel
like that doesn't i think that just sort
of adds to its like little indie movie
charm uh because there was a lot of that
kind of stuff going on around then i
just and i remember like all that music
and that you know the the clothes and
everything like that i don't know it
really gives it a little bit of a vibe
that i really like uh so yeah this is
kind of like it's kind of like a
frankenstein story um but it's doing its
own thing with it which you know it's
obviously like influenced by a lot of
other movies but it's it's doing its own
thing and so i think lucky mckee really
took all of these disparate elements
that he was into
and
kind of tied it together into this
really affecting
whole
um because like i said it's it's rare
for a horror movie to also kind of like
be
this sad and like this heartbreaking and
give you so much sympathy for someone
that is essentially a murderer but
because you see everything through her
perspective
you can understand like where she's
coming from even though you don't
obviously what she's doing is bad and
it's like is wrong
but
you understand how she got from point a
to point b and you feel so bad for her
that it's did it almost kind of like it
just makes it just such a tragic story
and like i said i really really love the
end where the where the friend like
ostensibly like comes to life i just
think it's like such a sweet ending but
also like super [ __ ] up because you
can tell that her mind is just
completely gone at this point but yeah
so if you haven't seen may from 2002 i
definitely definitely recommend it a lot
it's really really great and i feel like
it's really like i said kind of
underrated so if you are in the us i'm
not sure about other territories or
countries or whatever go over to 2b.tv
and it's free you can watch it on there
as at least as of this recording and if
you've seen it let me know what you
thought about it in the comments and i
will see you guys on the next flickers
of fear bye